blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman when joe biden and democrats were
able to pass their 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief bill there was some news
that
tax reform might be joe biden's next
a big legislative goal and we talked
last week about what is expected to be
in that tax reform plan we talked with
bill share
about the political feasibility
remembering that there are many
democrats who
don't necessarily support all aspects of
what joe biden wants to do
from the standpoint of tax reform but
now it looks like it may not actually be
tax reform that joe biden and his
administration tackle next there's a
report from the associated press
that it may be a very large a three
trillion dollar
i guess we're calling it an
infrastructure package but it's really
like
an infrastructure schools and families
package and a joe biden reportedly
monday met with senate democrats to
start laying the groundwork for what
would be
a spending package that would deal with
many aspects of american infrastructure
that are sadly outdated we've needed
like real i don't mean you drive
by and that stretch of road near your
house is under construction for two
years and it's never really clear what
they're doing but eventually it gets
done and i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about
major repair and replacement of
significant
american infrastructure we're talking
about a
new development of roads we're talking
about
a refreshing hospital infrastructure
green
energy systems you know a lot of these
different things
and reportedly this is exactly what joe
biden is looking at
next 3 trillion dollars in total
and it will include money for schools it
will include money
uh for families um and it would be
divided up
could be a third a third a third again
this is all early but it looks like it
could be about a trillion dollars
for roads bridges rail lines electrical
vehicle charging stations
and a cellular network and the idea
would be
start pushing towards clean energy but
do it in an in an
economically competitive way which is
what we've been saying
for all all this time the idea is not uh
necessarily uh to take things out of the
market but it's
let's have fair markets where we're not
subsidizing the wrong
things the second piece of it which is
the school piece
would include investments in workers by
providing free community college
universal pre-k pre-kindergarten and
paid
family leave another aspect that we've
been talking about for a while which
many on the right see
as quote handouts remember it's our tax
money that's then being
being used for programs to call them
handouts is wrong
fundamentally but it also ignores that
when you're doing something that
allows people to be more economically
productive it should fit under the
umbrella of what the so-called
free enterprise people would also want
now that three trillion dollar number is
obviously a number that is going to lead
to
the predictable and and uh uh regular
refrains
from the right and i think that
hopefully democrats will realize
we're not going to get votes from
republicans anyway so let's not
care about the fact that they're going
to talk about we don't have the money
where's the money going to come from etc
etc
they're going to do that regardless they
would do it if it was 2 trillion
they did it with 800 billion when it was
uh barack obama's spending program
they're going to do it regardless so
hopefully that's not something that is
going to be
um affecting the way that democrats go
about this and fundamentally as i said
when when donald trump lost and remember
we knew that on november 8th of 2020
we didn't have to wait until january
20th to know that
i said these two years will be a test
in two ways one can republicans
obstruct everything and still get
themselves re-elected
the answer may be yes and we'll actually
talk later today about how even though
every republican voted against covid
stimulus a few weeks ago
one-third of republicans republican
voters
think that their republican elected
officials voted for covet stimulus so
they may be able to obstruct
and not get punished by their voters
because their voters are so clueless
that's number one but number two
it's a test of what can you get done
when you have a two-year period
with the white house the house and the
senate we've seen these periods before
um and uh we we the infrastructure
spending needs to happen
it's been necessary for decades we are
able to count on zero republican
senators to vote for it their efforts
will be obstruction
because ultimately they are cult members
they uh turned over the party to donald
trump when it became clear that
trump had the momentum and even if
privately they they were opposed to what
trump was doing
they stood aside i guess because they
wanted to get their judges done or
whatever the case may be
and i know that one of the talking
points they may come up with
and and unfortunately this one resonates
even with some in my audience will be
three trillion dollars for all of this
different stuff why can't we just
separate it out
and do individual bills up and down
votes on each of these elements
and then it would be clearer what people
are in favor of or against because you
can always have republicans saying well
i'm not against doing some of this stuff
but we can't do all of it because of
item number one and item number seven
and twenty those are pork or those are
bad or whatever the case may be
what you have to remember is that bills
typically need
60 votes but you can get around that
through the budget reconciliation
process but you're limited
in how many times you can use that
process
once we know and we know that
republicans will not
actually negotiate in good faith they'll
find
if you change how you do the bill
they'll find you new ways to oppose it
what you have to understand is that
reconciliation and doing this with 50
votes plus kamala
is probably the only way you get it done
if you separate this out into four or
eight or 12 different bills
republicans will then just find ways to
delay each
individual bill they might use different
justifications or the same one
the only way you really have a shot at
getting this done
is by doing it all together in what's
called an omnibus bill
and passing it through budget
reconciliation so ultimately
they would say republicans oh break it
up and then we'll do individual votes on
the merits of each one of these
then they would just obstruct and use
delay tactics to make sure that as few
of those things actually get a vote in
the first place
and then they would still vote against
it in the end so i
i do think it's probably more
politically feasible
right now for biden to do this than the
tax stuff
that's that's a political feasibility
calculation
i think either way he's going to be
doing it with literally
zero republican support if you think
some republicans might vote for such a
spending bill
uh infrastructure bill let me know and
specifically let me know who
because i just don't see it there is
currently a
senator kennedy in the senate and he's
actually named john kennedy
but he's a republican he is not related
to the well-known
kennedys of of a democratic party fame
and in the wake of multiple major mass
shootings in the last week
senator kennedy has been doing the
rounds to equate
guns to cars insisting that listen
we don't ban cars because sometimes
people die in car accidents we don't ban
cars because sometimes people drive
drunk
and this could not be a sillier analogy
and we're going to talk about why in a
moment but understand that
at a top level even comparing cars and
guns is fraught
because of their intended purposes cars
were never designed to kill people or
animals or maim them
yes a car can be misused as a weapon
but it wasn't invented for that guns
were invented
to kill or maim people or animals and
sometimes
to threaten people with the fear of
doing that
yes guns can be used for target practice
that's not what they were invented for
most people don't own guns merely for
target practice
most car related deaths are accidents
most gun related deaths are deliberate
homicides and suicides
there are gun accidents as well okay so
the comparison
at a base level makes no sense senator
john kennedy
and some others don't care or don't know
here is john kennedy at a congressional
hearing earlier this week saying
we have lots of drunk driving deaths we
don't ban sober drivers from driving
but i do think we ought to keep this in
perspective
what has happened in the last few days
what's happened in the last
years is of course tragic
and i'm not i'm not trying to perfectly
equate these two but
we have a lot of drunk drivers in
america that kill
a lot of people
we ought to we ought to try to combat
that too
but i think what many folks on my side
of the aisle are saying is that the
answer is not
to get rid of all sober drivers
the answer is to concentrate on the
problem i guess senator kennedy
really liked this analogy because then
he appeared on fox news and made a
similar
car related analogy to guns during an
interview
with fox and friends host brian kilmeade
yesterday morning um but you you don't
stop
drunk drivers by getting rid of all
sober drivers
which is what many of my democratic
friends want to do with respect to the
second amendment
and my judgment we do not need more gun
control
we need more idiot control so part of
the problem with saying that this is
about
idiot control so therefore don't do
anything about guns
is that it's too easy for idiots in the
u.s to get guns in the first place and
there's too many idiots in the united
states
but the analogy to vehicles is
really a terrible one because we already
regulate
vehicles way more than we regulate
getting guns
john kennedy says let's not go crazy
with cars like some want to do with guns
because that would be bad
actually we do much more with drivers
and vehicles already to get a driver's
license in the first place
in most states you need to pass a
written test have a certain number of
practice hours pass a driving test renew
the license periodically sometimes that
includes an
eye exam if you get too many tickets you
lose your license
if you don't pay tickets you can lose
your license in most states the car has
to be insured
in most states you need to have the car
inspected yearly for safety depending on
the age of the car
there would be an emissions test to see
if it's road worthy based on
modern emission standards if you drive
drunk you can use your license or even
go to prison
it's not you know no one is suggesting
he says let's not do with cars what we
do
with what democrats want to do with guns
in reality
it's republicans who don't even want to
do with guns what we already do with
cars and drivers
i have many democratic and left-leaning
friends who own
firearms they all want universal
background checks
mandatory waiting period to get a gun
limits on certain types of weapons but
arguably
just as importantly limits on certain
ammunition purchases
mandatory re-licensing and testing and
mandatory gun insurance we have a second
amendment
i'm not disputing that none of my
left-leaning gun owner friends are
disputing that what we're disputing
is that we don't even make it as
difficult to get a gun
as we make it to get a driver's license
and that doesn't make
any sense whatsoever and a lot of this
stuff is actually not controversial
uh universal background checks you know
it ebbs and flows over time
but it's overwhelmingly popular with the
american people in the wake of the sandy
hook shooting it was like 88 to 90
support republicans just said no it was
a non-starter with republicans
a lot of this isn't controversial with
the american people
and it is a designed controversy
by the nra and other groups because they
just want to sell guns always the threat
of someone taking your gun is a great
way to get people to go and buy guns
before they make them illegal right this
is this is how the nra sells guns
and uh from the standpoint of elections
these are often for the right great
issues for raising money
um so terrible analogy cars and guns
doesn't make any sense
friday march 26th one day membership
special we're almost there
we had a pretty pretty pretty poor month
in february from the standpoint of
memberships a lot of cancellations
because of what's going
on economically so we're doing a vaccine
themed membership blowout on
friday if you want to get the
instructions for how to take advantage
of it
just get on my mailing list at
joinpakman.com
friday morning you'll get an email and
uh you'll be able to sign up at a huge
discount it's a beautiful thing
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist
to get a sample first just think how
much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
mostly funded by listeners and viewers
like you
through the membership program at
joinpacman.com and it comes with the
great benefit of an extra show
every day we do an additional show every
single day
for our members called the bonus show
world famous
malaysia the bonus show is huge in
malaysia
sign up at joinpakman.com so we've been
covering and talking about
these tragic major mass shootings over
the last
week in the united states one of them
took place in colorado
and as if we needed any kind of reminder
about the pernicious and depraved nature
of the nra the national rifle
association
consider that the nra bragged that it
helped
block a ban on ar-15s and high-capacity
magazines
in boulder colorado just days
before a shooter with exactly
that type of firearm killed 10 people
in boulder at a grocery store
think about that the nra bragging about
that
and after the shooting the nra actually
tweeted a defense of the second
amendment
if you can imagine anything more crass
and poorly timed
although maybe for them it's exactly the
right time to tweet this stuff
saying quote a well-regulated militia
being necessary to the security of a
free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
they are bragging about their role
in blocking a boulder colorado ban
on the exact type of weapon that six
days later was used for the shooting
and the nra tweeted about a decision
made
in boulder quote a colorado judge gave
law abiding gun owners something
to celebrate he ruled that the city of
boulder's ban
on commonly used ar-15s and 10-plus
round magazines
was preempted by state law and struck
them down this was a ban passed by the
boulder city council
unanimously in 2018. they passed in 2018
an assault weapons ban and a
high-capacity magazine
ban after the marjory stoneman douglas
school shooting in parkland florida
it has gone through appeals
and this fight and now the nra
celebrates we got them back the ar-15s
and then six days later one is used in
boulder colorado to kill 10 people and
what we have to remember and understand
is i mean listen first of all there is
no more depraved and backwards
organization in the u.s
than the national rifle association
maybe the republican party
but one of the most depraved and
backwards organizations
but you have to understand that the nra
is a business
lobby okay the who are the customers of
the nra
it's not the gun owners it's the gun
manufacturers
and the gun manufacturers make money by
selling guns democratic presidents
help to sell guns because the nra will
claim
that these democrats are going to come
and take your guns under barack obama
under the threats from the nra under the
announcements from the nra
that barack obama was a threat to your
gun ownership we saw record gun
sales under donald trump who was not
caricatured as the president that will
take your guns gun sales actually
declined
the other aspect of this and this is
you know it's just a reality mass
shootings
also sell guns for two reasons number
one
the nra comes in and says look at how
dangerous the world is out there
partially because the nra
has been so successful it's really
dangerous out there
you need guns and then so people go and
then they buy more guns
and then of course mass shootings also
sell guns
because after the mass shooting groups
like the nra and other gun rights groups
will say this is not the time for
democrats to come take your guns which
they want to do
which perpetuates people wanting to go
and stockpile even more
firearms and ammunition so as i said
earlier today
we have a second amendment i don't
dispute that my left-leaning
gun-owning friends don't dispute that
many of us
on the left have actually armed
ourselves
during the pandemic partially for fears
that
you know if these supply lines for you
know okay toilet paper
but maybe more critically uh other other
items medical
elements uh food whatever um
if if the supply lines are interrupted
for longer periods of time
many on the left saying i don't want the
right wingers to be the only ones with
the firearm so this is not about
contesting that there's a second
amendment or whatever
this is about the pernicious and
depraved nature of groups like the nra
whose answer is always more guns their
primary thing is
let's prevent bans on any types of
firearms and then their secondary thing
is
if it's safe out there we say it's safe
because of guns if it's dangerous out
there we say well you need more guns
if there's a democratic president
they're coming for your gun so you
should get them now
the answer is always more guns for the
nra
and it's hard to imagine at this point
um a more immoral organization
there probably are some but i'm
struggling to think of them
in january we did a segment about a
focus group
that pollster and researcher frank luntz
did with trumpists
about their media consumption and how
they end up
believing things about the election
and what we found out was not
particularly surprising a lot of fox
news a lot of news max a lot of oan it
was very eye-opening
frank luntz did another great focus
group a few days ago
with anti-vaccine trumpists these are
trumpists
who are hesitant to get the coronavirus
vaccine and we're going to look at some
clips here but the big takeaway
is that our suspicions about
anti-vaccine republicans and trumpists
appear to basically be correct which is
that a full year
of disinformation from trump uh
downplaying the pandemic
downplaying its severity that's a big
part of why trumpists and republicans
now
uh in great proportion do not plan to
get the coronavirus vaccine so let's get
right into it with the first clip
then we'll talk about it when i say
covet 19
vaccination vaccine adam what do you
think of first
um a miracle albeit suspicious
lauren i'm sure too many questions
patrick rush
god from california experimental
aaron impressive but hesitant
gary not knowing the long-term side
effects
chad long-term side effects
unknown matthew experimental
and unknown how will effect
long term david from texas
long-term side effects diane from ohio
unproven lisa uh efficacy
unknown so these responses about the
vaccine
range from the suspicious to the
completely debunked talking points
for example unproven and efficacy
unknown for example
it's quite the opposite the phase three
trials of these vaccines
approve that these are some of the first
most effective vaccines ever developed
by humans or or
by anybody i don't know how many
vaccines have been developed by animals
but
these are some of the most successful
vaccines and effective ones ever
developed
huge efficacy at preventing symptomatic
illness period
and almost perfect at preventing serious
illness
we know that that's not an unknown
quantity they just don't know
rushed we've gone over this many times
the mrna platform
under development for decades
specifically
so that when you have a need for a
specific vaccine it's a faster process
it wasn't rushed
this is how long it takes to develop
mrna vaccines
possible long-term side effects you can
always say that
about any vaccine at any time the polio
vaccine was developed in 1955 that's 66
years ago
one could say how do we know side
effects don't start at the 67
year mark what we know about vaccines
and how they work this idea of
some future effect
is not a concern based on all of the
best medical science
so then they get into where do these
ideas come from
it's remarkable but it's also pretty
predictable
oh frank can i just say that it's all
very logical like i looked at this
logically there's no you know
craziness of because i think one way
politically that i can't look at logic
and reason
and i think what you said very kind of
cavalierly about
so what that the pharmaceuticals let the
results out five days after the election
and to me that's a big so what it just
it makes you doubt a little bit of the
motives and the politization of science
so if you really want us to trust the
science i think politics has to be taken
out of it
and also if we could be if we could be
told that by being vaccinated things
would get back to normal again
and they don't even you know when that
happened and that happened
but that's not happening no things don't
wear masks yeah
right still mask don't get together with
family but i didn't say the other night
oh you could have a small gathering by
fourth of july
maybe maybe if we behave
i mean that's to me if everyone's
getting vaccinated
we gotta move on and what you just saw
was what happens when politics gets put
in the middle of this
it's just got to come out somehow i i
think that that is going to be key to
all of this
that and ask yourself ask yourself who
put the politics there
which side had a benefit to having
politics introduced to this
and now they just keep it going it's not
going to be taken out now that last
comment is interesting who had an
interest
in injecting politics into this
one of the focus group participants said
the injection of politics for personal
benefit
on this pandemic in the united states
was trump and republicans
democrats had no interest in this case
in injecting politics democrats just
wanted to say let's do what the doctors
say
let's do what the public health experts
say trump calculated
if i downplay this if i disagree
with the public health experts it'll go
away and that's best for me
it's better for me politically not to
take this seriously at least publicly
and if it hadn't been that serious
donald trump would have been easily
re-elected
i've said that before if trump handled
the virus well he also would have been
re-elected
but the global handling of the virus
actually tells us that the best
political strategy
is the same as the best medical strategy
you step aside
and you listen to doctors new zealand
did it
australia did it taiwan did it rwanda
did it
uh there's other countries as well the
leaders where
i mean okay paul kagame in rwanda didn't
need to do well that's a different
situation but you look at new zealand
and other other places
when they did well with the virus they
did well politically and the best way to
deal
well uh with the virus was just to do
what the doctors said
but these folks believe that it's
democrats who injected politics
trump made a political call not a
medical call to say 15 cases will soon
be zero
he privately knew how much more serious
it was but he continued to downplay it
publicly
it was trump who initially injected
politics
let's continue it's not right nope the
fear-mongering started at the beginning
and it's never ended
right and if there was a fact that i
want to see
i want to see the data point that says
when we reach herd immunity
and what percentage is there a
percentage of the population that could
be vaccinated and then we're hurt
immunity
because i have a minute the minute they
tell
you that the goal pulse will move again
right because it was how many days until
we're done
and we can take off our masks and three
weeks until if we all do this and it'll
be over
and we're tired of that they set it up
and then it moves and so
how do you trust that if we all get to
vaccination level
we're going to be done with this and
don't forget the who changed the
definition of herd immunity
from natural to vaccinated
so talk about politicizing science
fear-mongering nearly 600 000 dead
officially probably 750 000 dead if you
include unreported or unofficial
covet deaths what's funny about saying
we don't trust anything now because we
were told this would be over in three
weeks
those were the political statements
trump made in 2020 think about the
the lack of logic there they don't trust
biden now
they don't trust the vaccine now they
don't trust the government now
because trump said it'll be over by
easter of 2020
when obviously it wasn't going to be
over by easter of 2020.
they don't seem to realize that their
current mistrust of biden
who is being honest now about here's
what's going well but it could get worse
and i'll
if this isn't going so well i'm going to
tell you
that distrust of biden is based on
things
trump told them that were wrong now this
next clip is very interesting
i've guessed that even anti-vaccine
trumpists
once they see there are going to be
businesses that say we will require a
vaccine
maybe to fly with us maybe to go to a
concert that we organize whatever
that's going to get more people wanting
the vaccine
a bunch of the trumpists in the focus
group do say
travel requirements for example would
push me to get a vaccine not all of them
but some take a look
i'm not going to let you board a plane
without having a passport a digital
passport
that says that you got the covid19
vaccine
if that were the case how many of you in
this
on this group how many of you would get
the vaccine
if you knew that you could not get on a
plane
okay so debbie would i would delay it as
long as possible
i wouldn't i wouldn't rush to do it i
would just i would change my travel
plans yeah okay lauren you would do it
i love to travel i've been sitting you
know we haven't traveled
um i'm used to going away three four
times a year so if i if this is the only
way i could go away i i i'm gonna have
to take the
hands jen you would get jan from
iowa you get the vaccine if it meant
that you could travel by flight
i think eventually i would cave and i
would get the vaccine
even though like my husband and i both
survived covet last month
um he almost died but i still think that
at some point i might be forced to do it
and it would i would rather it be my
choice
than it be forced upon me by other
entities debbie if it meant you not
being able to fly or you being able to
fly you would get the vaccine
i would get the vaccine i absolutely we
love to travel
and we love to take cruises and so i
would i would
i would get it to travel so as you can
see some of them say
no no even to travel i'm not getting a
vaccine
but some of them say no i really like to
travel i'd probably get vaccinated if i
needed to
a a reluctant vaccinated person is still
vaccinated and that's
that that that's still i think the the
way the focus uh should remain
one other moment that's interesting
frank luntz brought in dr tom frieden
who's a former cdc director and tom
frieden
gave the focus group participants five
facts about vaccines
it actually changed a lot of minds dr
fredon
i'm gonna go to you now because doug
says he wants facts
let's go give them facts and let's see
if you can move them right now
one if you get infected with the virus
it will go all over your body and stay
there for at least a week
and be much more likely to cause you
long-term problems
than the vaccine two if you get the
vaccine
it will prime your immune system but
then the vaccine is gone
it will not be with you anymore three
more than 95 of the doctors who have
been
offered this vaccine have gotten it as
soon as they can
four the more we vaccinate
the faster we can get back
to growing our economy and getting jobs
and five if people get vaccinated
we're going to save at least a hundred
thousand lives
of americans who would otherwise be
killed by coven okay
i want to show of hands how many of you
would say that those five facts are
impactful to you
raise your hands if they're impactful
yeah wow wow that's a lot of you so most
people raised their hands there so the
upside
is not all is lost vaccination is
continuing to accelerate
we are now officially averaging 2.5
million doses per day
hopefully going to three we'll have a
full report on that tomorrow
but enough of these folks are
suffering the effects of such aggressive
disinformation
and confusion and partisanship
that mathematically we're probably still
up against a pretty difficult situation
in terms of getting to herd immunity
on a national level in areas with less
vaccine hesitancy
it does seem like herd immunity is going
to be achievable
but we're going to have to hope that
travel restrictions or whatever
do push more of these folks to
ultimately get the vaccine
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram
find us there at david pakman show
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
one of the things we talked about after
0.0 republicans in the house or senate
voted for joe biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar coveted relief bill was
will these republican elected officials
who voted against the bill
that even many republican voters wanted
the the coveted relief bill remember had
about 70 percent support you don't get
that with just democrats that means
independents and republicans as well
we wondered will any of these republican
elected officials suffer consequences as
a result of voting against that bill
and we quickly saw even though they all
voted against it
some republicans publicly taking credit
for the fact that the bill was passed
and actually saying
it's good that people are getting this
or that or the other thing it's actually
even worse than this
a new poll finds that a third of
republican voters
believe that republican lawmakers
did vote for the covid relief bill
remember
nobody in the not a single republican in
the house voted in favor of the coveted
relief bill a couple of weeks ago
not a single republican in the senate
voted in favor of the coveted relief
bill one guy in the senate was missing
he didn't vote one way or the other not
a single one
and yet data for progress and vox
conducted a poll
of republican voters and 53 percent
knew that their republican lawmakers
did not vote for the bill but 31
said yeah they did vote for the bill and
17 percent didn't know
that means that 48 of republicans
um either wrongly believed
that their elected officials voted for
the 1400 stimulus checks that most of
them are getting
or simply didn't know one way or the
other now you might say well this is
probably a problem on the left as well
it is
but only to a fraction of a degree just
16 percent of democratic voters
thought republicans voted in favor of it
just 16 percent of independent voters
thought republicans voted in favor of
the coveted relief bill
so what you have here if if you're if
the question you're trying to answer
is will there be repercussions for
republicans for voting against it
the answer is probably not number one
because the opportunity for
repercussions is still almost two years
away in the 2022 election
and number two because a whole bunch of
these republicans think
that their elected officials did vote in
favor of the bill
and this is exactly why i said there may
not
be that much of a political risk to
these republicans
for voting against because their
constituents still get the money
even though they voted against when it's
convenient they can say
i oppose the wasteful spending on
fill in the blank um and then they can
still get themselves reelected because
their voters are completely clueless
now as far as the voters go
is this surprising not really
if you're able to be bamboozled into
thinking donald trump can fix
trade immigration health insurance
income inequality wages i mean you know
if you got tricked into that
then i could understand how you would
wrongly believe republican
senators and members of the house voted
for a bill they didn't vote for
if you fell for trump saying
the virus is just the flu and 15 cases
will be zero
and the covid vaccine could give you
covid and masks
are bad and don't work and a reflection
of suppression of freedom and all of
this other stuff as
half a million people die if you can
fall for that stuff
it's pretty plausible to believe that
you will just wrongly
assess whether your representative voted
for or against the coveted relief bill
that's not really surprising if you fell
for
biden's a socialist biden takes over
we're not we're going to have
toilets you have to flush 15 times and
no windows and no heat and no air
conditioning and
it's all going to be socialism and
communism if you fell for that this is
like
child's play this is this is like
nothing so
of course right wingers uh mostly
uh about 50 50 they wanted the stimulus
most of them got it of course since most
of the country qualified for the 1400
checks they gladly accepted the free
money that counts as
socialism when they're hearing about the
things that joe biden is going to do
and in the end many of them a third of
them
and close to half if you include the
ones who don't know
think that their elected officials who
tried to prevent them from getting the
money
actually helped them get it it's
absolutely stunning stuff and as i've
said before
when you don't even have an agreement as
to
not what the facts are but
what facts are meaning what is a fact
and what is an opinion
when you don't even have agreement there
and understanding on that
people will fall for anything and that
explains donald trump
and it explains so much of what we've
seen over the last five years
in thinking about the future of the
republican party
we've talked about is the future a
return
to the sort of mccain romney wing of the
republican party
is the future a trumpian q anon
type dominated republican party is it
a fractured party where someone goes off
and
takes their toys home meaning trump
leaves the party and starts his own
or more traditional republican parties
leave the party and start their own
and the answer is we just don't know yet
as we talked about donald trump
announcing at a cpac speech at the end
of february
that he wants republicans not to donate
to the party but to donate to his pac
and he will decide which republicans to
primary because they're bad republicans
and on the other hand which republicans
to support
basically because they support donald
trump okay speaking
on the debut episode of the lisa booth
show donald trump was interviewed
and named names as to who
he believes is the future of the
republican party
and it's mostly just people that suck up
to trump
i don't think it'll be surprising to you
to hear that um
the people that donald trump believes
are the future of the republican party
include
florida governor ron desantis who from
the beginning of the
coronavirus pandemic resisted doing
anything in florida cow towed to trump
placated trump kept as much open for as
long as possible
trump says ron desantis is part of the
future of the republican party
senators josh hawley ted cruz and rand
paul
you'll remember that back in the 2016
republican primary
trump and cruz didn't really get along
cruz saying some ugly things about
trump trump literally implying
that ted cruz's wife is ugly so a lot of
ugly there but ultimately ted cruz came
around to donald trump
uh rand paul major trump brown noser
became a friend of trump's during the
campaign
during the presidency playing golf with
trump josh hawley
arguably the most prominent senator who
on january 6th tried to actually prevent
the electoral votes from being counted
so we know why they are there
south dakota governor christie gnome
she has been a big trump suck-up to some
degree maybe she's on the list because
trump finds her attractive that's always
a possibility with donald trump as well
and then of course arkansas republican
gubernatorial candidate
sarah huckabee sanders a massive trump
suck-up who has importantly remained
loyal after she left the administration
remember that sarah huckabee sanders was
a donald trump's press secretary
for some period of time so these are the
people trump says are the future
he said quote i think we have a lot of
people we have a lot of
young good people ron desantis is doing
a really good job in florida josh hawley
has shown
real courage in going after big tech you
know they go after him
josh is terrific somebody that's been
really terrific is ted cruz
trump said he and i had it out for a
while actually we were very close
even during the campaign and then it got
nasty the press would say when's the
nastiness going to start i said don't
worry it'll start and it got very
violent
but he's been great essentially meaning
eventually ted cruz just
prayed at the altar of trump and then uh
trump mentioning a few other names and
saying he's very confident in the talent
pool
calling the republican party stacked
stacked so the the strategy here is very
clear
if trump can be a successful king maker
in 2022
and decide who gets primaried and loses
and decide
who he backs who gets reelected if he
can effectively pick the winners
and losers in 2022 it better positions
him
for 2024. he was asked in this interview
with lisa booth
whether whether and when he will decide
about throwing his hat in the ring he
just didn't say anything about it yet
um and it seems very very clear that if
trump
fails to control the party in 2022 he's
unlikely to run
uh and i think even if he succeeds he
may not run because he'll just be
uh you know older tired or bored with
the idea
by 2024 if trump successfully
runs the 2022 primary in particular
if the people he chooses help to take
control back of the house or senate from
democrats in 2022
i think at least trump will be able to
make the case that he is still
the most powerful figure in the party
and may run in 2024.
the names on trump's list not hugely
surprising
whether trump will succeed at this in
2022 certainly remains to be seen
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show all right um
this is something a little different you
know i get
so many emails probably like eight to
ten emails a week from people who either
want to start a podcast youtube channel
or independent media show
or who have started it but it's not
going as well as they want and they want
advice from me and
it's beyond the scope of the 24 hours
that i have in the day to be doing
too much of this kind of individual
guidance but there are a bunch of
different people over the years that
have come to me for
advice people i know personally or
people that are introduced to me
and they often have very similar
questions
and the point of failure for almost
everybody is exactly the same
and i sort of tweeted about this
yesterday and a bunch of people wrote
back and said you should really kind of
talk about this
um being you know as not we're i believe
in the top
point one percent of youtube at this
point and uh having done it and having
gotten to the point of hiring staff and
having a successful business model
what is it that causes people to fail
and unfortunately
fortunately or unfortunately the the
good i have good news and bad news and
it's all the same
the biggest single point of failure is
essentially not showing up
um when i will talk to people who have
started shows or want to
uh they often will jump to things like
how do i negotiate a brand deal what
should my youtube thumbnails look like
what kind of equipment do i need for my
podcast
when can i monetize and so often the
cart
is being put before the horse and what i
tell everybody is
all of that stuff will come naturally
you'll figure that stuff out when the
time comes once
you are actually steadily and
consistently
and reliably producing the content this
this isn't like the bogus 98
is showing up this is just the reality
that people will often focus on things
that aren't the most important now
obviously if your content is terrible
some people just like they're you know
the content is not good
assuming that your content isn't
terrible
where almost everybody fails is they get
discouraged
too early there are overnight successes
in independent media of course there are
um but the vast majority are not
and people will come to me and i'll say
you need to pick a content schedule and
stick to it are you doing a weekly show
are you doing daily youtube clips are
you doing a twice a week show
or what is the format and the timeline
that you are
committing to and sometimes people will
hear that
um and and they will keep it going you
know i remember in fact
years and years ago meeting up with kyle
kolinsky
when both of our channels were much
smaller and
the thing we talked about as we both
were looking to grow
at the time that he actually did and he
now has a channel that that is doing
really well
is you've got to commit to the schedule
of content that's
actually the key thing we didn't talk
about monetization
brand deals thumbnails we we talked
maybe about
you know what microphone do you use but
it was all about the content and so i'll
have conversations with people
and ninety percent of the conversation
is about things that don't really make a
difference
and then they'll say yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna do the content six months go by
i'll come across their youtube channel
and it'll say oh their their latest
video is six weeks old
you've done no content for six weeks and
sometimes we'll have another interaction
and they'll say
yeah you know it just wasn't as
lucrative as i wanted it to be it's like
well but you're not publishing the
content
you have to do that first the other big
mistake
is sometimes just scaling up expenses
before it's time
i know of shows that are one-tenth the
size of our show
where the host will tell me they already
have
an executive assistant who responds to
their email and schedules their
interviews
what what that doesn't make any sense
and i
from a business standpoint i've talked
before about the push cart method one of
my mba
professors would talk about the push
cart method don't necessarily go to a
restaurant with an expensive lease and
tons of employees
try the food with a push cart a
food cart and if it does well then you
roll that into maybe getting the
restaurant and this is like
the the most important thing that i that
i tell people
and most of them fail to do it and there
are tons of shows that could do fine the
content's good
um but people just don't show up and so
you know unfortunately i i at this point
i'm unable to provide individualized
advice
to all the people who email me but if
you're not doing the content
don't be surprised that none of the
other stuff is going as well as you want
it to go
hopefully that's useful to some people
and i think that that's what we
committed to early with the show which
was when we were twice a week
we were twice a week and we were doing
the content and we were putting up the
clips in the podcast episodes
when we went to when when that was
supported
financially we then went to four times a
week and we did it
and then when that was supported
financially we went to the five
and people can count on the content it's
the most important thing
it's the biggest point of failure and
the real reason why tons of people i
mean
it's dozens and dozens of people over
time who have emailed me saying
i want to do what you're doing but it's
just not happening you didn't do the
main thing i said which is commit to the
content schedule
i used to watch jeopardy when i was
younger but i admit it's been
decades since i've really watched
jeopardy but one of the big things about
jeopardy under the tutelage of the great
alex trebek
was that it was just about facts and
empiricism that's what it was about
and unfortunately that's the exact
opposite
of pseudoscience pushing dr mehmet oz
mehmet oz is like a tv he's a real
doctor he's there's no
he's a real doctor but he's also you
know like a tv doctor who appears on
different shows
uh often giving uh giving medical advice
and after the passing of long-time
jeopardy host alex trebek
jeopardy has tried a number of different
guest hosts and
this week uh or for a two-week period
actually the guest host is dr mehmet oz
to me this is pathetically embarrassing
it's
you to put a uh in front of
for a show that is supposed to be about
just the facts
and empiricism to put in a guy who for
years has been peddling
all sorts of quackery and pseudoscience
seems completely antithetical to what
jeopardy is about
i don't really care in the sense that i
don't even watch this show
but there are tons of jeopardy fans who
are absolutely
furious about this and i have to tell
you i actually get it
i actually get it why do you put on a
pseudo-science doctor to host a show
about facts
a dr oz has previously uh pushed
various weight loss products including a
green coffee extract which is completely
and utterly not based in any kind of
science whatsoever
and in fact even the claims that the
company
based their uh marketing on
have since been retracted dr oz has
pushed the idea that gmos are
unhealthy now i know this is unpopular
with some on the left
there is no scientific evidence that
gmos are unhealthy by virtue of being
gmos yes there is overlap between gmos
and pesticides
and there are all sorts of deleterious
effects associated with
pesticides but there is not evidence
that
gmos are unhealthy i know some of you
will get mad and say david but
that's not been studied it has been
studied
go to scholar.google.com and find
endless peer-reviewed even long-term
studies on gmos
dr oz has pushed cures for the common
cold
including something called um calabo
root extract there is no science to back
that up
it can have side effects and dr oz has
pushed it
dr oz has talked about cures for
restless leg syndrome which include
putting lavender soap under your bed
sheets
because the floral smell may be relaxing
[Music]
no scientific research supports that
claim he's talked about
you know do-it-yourself teeth whitening
mess methods that involve
strawberries this is not who should be
hosting jeopardy
and i'm not arguing for anybody to be
canceled
i don't even care what jeopardy does
they can do whatever they want
but it seems like you know we actually
have a show here based on empirical
knowledge and facts
and you bring on dr oz i don't like it
you tell me
if uh you think i'm right or if i'm
wrong or if it just doesn't really
matter and i shouldn't even be talking
about it on the david pakman show
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a a comment about the recent
mass shootings and joe biden hey david
jerry calling from san antonio
right i was just curious how long do you
think it'll be before
the 21 year old syrian born shooter a
mass shooter in colorado who killed 10
people
will be blamed on joe biden's airstrikes
in syria
i haven't heard it blamed on biden's
syrian air strikes yet doesn't mean it
won't be
but i have already seen um
biden wanting to take guns is
responsible for the shootings and i
don't even i didn't even
maybe i'm too stupid maybe the problem
is me i didn't understand the connection
but i saw that biden's anti-gun agenda
is to blame for the shootings also since
so so right-wing media already was
undercovering
the shooting in georgia because it was a
white perpetrator
who killed asian people a lot of the
right wing net
networks ignored that altogether or
barely mentioned it
now that we know the shooter um
in colorado is muslim right wing network
networks are going absolutely
completely bonkers falling over
themselves to talk about that while
still barely mentioning the one from
days before so everybody is doing
exactly what we would expect them to do
maybe the syrian airstrikes will be
pointed to as the reason why this
shooting took place although i haven't
heard it yet
we have a great bonus show for you today
oakland is launching a guaranteed pay
plan for low-income people
very interesting idea the south dakota
governor is trying to block trans
athletes from women's sports not just in
south dakota but nationally
howe will explain it and unfortunately
roads are getting deadlier for
pedestrians it's not just
drivers who are seeing an increased rate
of fatalities
over the last year it is also
pedestrians and we will talk about
that on today's bonus show as well
how do you get the bonus show really
easy go to joinpakman.com and sign up
that's it go to joinpakman.com and sign
up
you'll get instant access to the
membership
benefits which include commercial free
audio and video streams of the show as
well as the daily bonus show
you can use the coupon code better21 if
you want a discount
don't feel obligated and you can also
get bonus show access
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i will see you then
we're back tomorrow we're back friday
then we are
off for a week just a reminder we'll be
off next week
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman